[Music]
Gussie was like a thousand years ago I
fought my way out of that cave became
Iron Man
[Music]
realized I loved you
and we said no more surprises but I was
really hoping to pull off one last one
but weld estranged
none of us
or we can do it is our best
and sometimes the best we can do
[Music]
I saw all these people die
I keep telling everybody they shouldn't
move on
someday Alanis
[Music]
even if there's a small chance
we owe this
everyone who's not in this room to try
[Music]
we will
whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes
whoever it takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
I like this one
on an island off the coast of Scotland
something was summoned from the depths
of hell
something that would envy mankind the
sir thing worried about to show up yes
you did
we face every threat there is and yet
you take me in
hello son made me a gun weapon where's
my fire there
mr. Loeb ladies and gentlemen out there
there's a fifth-century sorceress who
wants to bring down the curtain on
London of the world
great homework
[Music]
why do you fight for those who hates and
fear you
you are meant for this out of the ashes
okay I'd appreciate a prophecy with more
relatable stakes we've got to be saving
the world or something yeah okay come on
let's get you in free song
yeah come on let's do this
[Music]
we belong together here inside
we do but it's not gonna work you know
cuz I'm a Capricorn and you're not
daily backs
I wish you as a change
I use my powers for become yours
she's wait for you okay
[Music]
that's crazy right what are your
superpowers super four hours dude I
don't even know how to pee in this thing
[Music]
electricity manipulation
hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of
your finest beer please is Kathy Sparkle
fingers no it's not it's not me that's
not my name those who look like a bad
guy
you really did the opposite of what a
superhero is supposed to do you're him
you're the hero
I want basically 15
[Music]
yeah you electrocuted a bus and almost
killed these people and then I caught it
and they've tall buildings in a single
bound
[Music]
why did you enter this competition like
to sing a lot of people like to sing you
can missing but you're an inexperienced
performer with a Polish name entering a
competition that relies on the public
vote I never dreamed I would make it
this far
[Music]
sing from here mum
see how he's doing he's not a real
manager or anything but he has a lot for
me we can do a lot more you can do this
pilot you can do this
sing from your heart I had a way
losing it we would like to offer violets
a contract but you have to sign before
the shower it's a no-go
that's the deal to be the darkest you
are to be
[Music]
why me you're a caterpillar where a
cocoon maybe together we make a
butterfly
Tricia I'm very sorry about your loss I
can't even imagine how you must feel
your children reading would say are safe
now
I thought they heard her crying and they
felt this thing of reduce
they will
and she will come for the
I don't know the church works with
people who specialize in the situation's
language gets a lot your honor is she
coming she's all right here
we are facing an evil
no bells
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
call and text everyday moments college
it's not a survival course it'll be fine
[Music]
there okay are you a virgin I'll do dare
I dare you to make out with her I'm done
playing this game I like this girl
deep question who is hard and sky I
think that it's better if we keep our
distance welcome to my favorite place
[ __ ] that you just wanted to runs I
don't think we can ever be just friends
[Music]
cuz I just can't stop thinking about you
you are stunning
[Music]
nothing could ever change the way that I
feel about you just be careful what
happened it has to do with heart
something's going on but it's not what
you think it's making a big mistake
it's got a preacher
why are you dreaming about in the woods
today
la discovered a charming little land
work but that sanitary place to bury our
pets and remember them which seems scary
but it's not perfectly natural
just like dying is natural whole town's
been using this place for generations
folks make a kind of ritual out of it
it's not some campfire story
so these are the trees up there they're
warnings the local tribes carved them
before they fled they fear that place
there's something up there something
that dates way back
those would belong to something else
something that cat was dead they'll
bring these things back
[Music]
I know what you're thinking of doing but
they don't come back the same
de Wit scoyoc you daughter I should
never have shown you that place your
child is not the only thing that will
come back
the barrier is broken
we have a second chance sometimes debt
is better
well he ever given you
Walla
when you wake are you falling sound cord
shiverpool fantasy company or firewall
Chimayo
job is you're watching me harder
what's a member her to watch okay eat
okay
[Music]
what
mr. cha
[Music]
Antarctica
home to the deadly leopard seal the
mighty killer whale
and Steve a gentleman who stands out
from the crowd
[Music]
he's looking for love he likes long
walks on the beach
dreamy fishing and collecting rocks
[Music]
lucky for him
he's found his match
but when his other half leaves him alone
with the kids he discovers that being a
father is more than he bargained for
next Earth Day
Disneynature invites you to join an
extraordinary couple ah
fighting to raise a family in one of the
most unforgiving and stunning places on
earth
Disney nature's penguins birthday 2019
rise and shine breakfast is ready in ten
minutes and don't make me come back up
there this is our time it's a close-knit
community the kind of place where
everyone knows everyone
understood hey who are you girls and
we're always there for each other nice
sermon pastor well you guys have on for
the rest today
well done has a basketball game yeah
I've seen this guy goop it up around
here this kid is so rich text your mom
tomorrow until I win and where to pick
you up and don't do anything stupid
[Applause]
Simmi he's been underwater for more than
15 minutes it's going to be a recovery
I'm gonna rescue you've done everything
medically possible there's nothing more
with you do please God send your spirit
there's a muscle
a fourteen-year-old st. Charles boy who
spent 15 minutes trapped underwater is
continuing to fight for his life
I don't believe John will survive the
night you don't know my son he is a
fighter so I need you to be the best for
John and you just let God do the rest
you are my pride and joy I can't wait to
see you because baskets and run up and
down again the Smith family asks for one
thing
please pray for John in the water that
day I was ready to give up but then I
hear this voice is telling me go back
there are nuts or gods talking to you
but I don't believe in God I believe but
maybe that only goes so far something
like this out of your pasture I'm
supposed to walk alongside you for as
long as it takes
did you see the Facebook page it's going
viral
call me I hope is going to be okay
we're not gonna get through this alone
whatever you have for me
[Music]
I offer you a glimpse of a legendary
creature lost in time
neither ape nor man but a giant he's had
many neighbors
actually I go by Susan
so Susan yeah Susan that is a girl's
name yes that's correct
it suits you I need someone who knows
the wild places of the world and you're
the world's greatest adventure exactly
with me
I'm lonely I'm the last of my kind but
on the other side of the world they talk
of this creature of a Yeti
I think these yetis are my cousins can
you take me there I give you my word
okay what is it what your word now it's
a figure of speech sounds good what is
it well I'm on we have a long way to go
you'll need a map Harvey Bravo thank you
now to find the place you belong you
need to keep a low profile oh boy
that is gonna let in an awful dress
so let me see if I understand you plan
to travel around the world to the home
of the Yeti I know the secret ways to
the mountains you'll see come what you
do do not mention that [ __ ] no chicken
got it zip hmm
greetings venerable Gamu it is an honor
what's with the chicken it will not be
easy but we will find it your place
shangri-la we call it
what does it mean keep out we hate you
throw me out of the pit I think you
might be a little too heavy nonsense now
give it all you've got
oh it's hard to know whose fault that
was let's do it again
[Music]